hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the virtual cabin in Friday the 13th the
game is finally back again and it is a
must for Jason fans as its jam-packed
with references to the film's there are
literally hundreds but that's not why
we're here today there are so many
hidden easter eggs to find so I thought
we'd ignore all those easily found
secrets and find those ultra rare ones
together there may be a jump-scare or
two ahead of us so be warned about that
are you ready let's do this on the menu
screen select offline play and virtual
cabin this will load up version 1.0
remember this because we'll be seeing it
quite a few times once inside the cabin
frolic to your heart's content
you can even purr through a keyhole at a
scantily clad counselor or two if that's
your bag once you've finished perving
you'll notice books magazines and
newspapers with a word guess clue on the
back the newspaper is week one a furry
friend with a purple bow if you know
your Friday the 13th then you've already
summarized the answer is muffin the blue
mark underneath the answers tells us
which letter we need to remember so in
this case it's M I won't spoil any more
of these if you want to find them
yourself but the combined answer makes
up the word mother by the front door is
a computer from the 1980s activate it
and select check for updates you'll need
a password to get any further but of
course we've already got it mother
you'll be shown a list of new areas to
enjoy and now the ability to pick up
items and Crouch has been added to your
skill set once again look around the
house and have fun but when you're ready
go to the diorama in the first room of
the cabin our task now is to put these
characters in the right Jason nativity
scene so pick up all the characters and
head to the new room with the red door
at the center in the far corner is yet
another diorama
[ __ ] snakes get the [ __ ] out of me the
first time I played once again grab all
the characters here let's start with
this diorama as it looks like a scene
from Part three so let's put them down
in this order alley on the left then
part three Jason in the middle and now
we have an issue we need Chris well
Ali's not lost he can be found in the
bathroom in a box be careful not to
become mesmerized by Jenny's backside
grab Chris and bring him back and pop
him on the right back over to the other
diorama which looks like a nod to the
final Friday film this time use Jessica
Jason and Steven and the draw offers you
a badge or a secret patch if you prefer
run to the kitchen and next to the
lights which is a mount for four patches
this is our task let's find the other
three upstairs you'll notice a shrine to
Jason with many of his masks but some of
them are missing too the first mask is
in the back bedroom in the blue tent
remember to crouch to get there the next
mask is in the fireplace downstairs and
finally the third mask is in the red
door room in a box grab all of these and
take down all the masks on the shrine -
the masks must be placed in
chronological order so here's what
you're looking for this is a shrine for
Jason so one of these masks doesn't
belong here
take down the blue Chevron mask as that
was worn by someone pretending to be
Jason and once you've done that another
draw will open and reward you for your
detective skills the next patch requires
use of these column things first we need
all the objects a police badge which is
in the same room as the red door a blue
hat which can be found by the front door
upstairs in the blue tent room open the
wardrobe that's the first jump scare
here that didn't actually make me shoot
myself cuts down here and take the yo-yo
and finally the bandana is in the
bathroom
damn you Jenny's butt and here's why you
put them the back exit to the right of
the kitchen hides a plinth behind the
door
pop the blue cap here in the red door
room place the red bandana upstairs in
the bloody bedroom place the yo-yo and
finally place the star in the blue tent
room we are getting there only one patch
depending on how OCD you are place the
patches now or crack on I couldn't
figure out the next patch so I must
thank read it here get your backside
over to the phone and dial one five by
five three four two nine two seven seven
and you'll be greeted like this grab the
last patch and take it home to unlock a
secret bunker downstairs is an awesome
Jason tribute museum with two cabinets
still covered by the end of this video
we will uncover both the incessant phone
ringing in the back of the room will
become so annoying you'll be faster can
tell your tour and answer it
and we've done it we finished it no we
haven't no we haven't
buckle down we've got so much more to
uncover as the cabin loads in again we
are now up to version 1.3 feel free to
look around again a few little changes
can be found but to activate our next
task we need to use that computer again
and change the date to June 13th 1979
that's when the majority of the first
film takes place changing the date will
cause the phone to ring in the basement
again
go on go answer it
following the power cut we are locked in
the Jason Museum until we check out the
axe by the power relay once complete we
can now venture back upstairs
but one of the Jason's has now broken
free and is killing everyone in the
house even Jenny and her perfect but
remember the room we could spy in
earlier
well that room is now open and only a
cop's remains but hang on there was two
of them earlier where's the other one
check out the back of the door for
another gruesome murder and while you're
here grab the key from around his neck
if everything is going to plan the front
door will now be smashed open and we can
frolic outside as always go for a look
around and come back to me when you're
ready to move on on the beach is our
escape method the boat which requires
fuel but you've guessed it it's locked
behind another one of those patch quests
just by the campfire is your car in
front of that is a locked refrigerator
the padlock code is five three one two
you'll be gifted with everyone's
favorite Christmas present Pamela's head
you know run up to Jason Shack at the
top of the hill to put Pamela as the
table ornament she was meant to be and
here's our first patch for outside you
did good next go back down the hill all
the way past the cabin and use the key
you found to open up the little shack
inside is a shovel and we are going
digging walk up to the cemetery and
locate Jason's grave you know what to do
start shoveling how the heck do we wake
him up though we need a conductor look
around the fence for it then jab it
straight into Jason's torso and watch
the carnage
once you awake be sure to grab the patch
and look around again and yes everyone
is dead again two patches down and our
final task is to follow a maze but we
have to follow it perfectly all this
happens
starting at the stop sign
walk forward to the machete it's
pointing in your next direction simply
follow it to the tree carving then to
the arrow then to the ducks and finally
a shallow grave
grab your shovel and dig up muffin he
hasn't aged well
take our last patch and you've done it
unlock the fuel and make your escape
across the lake
but wait Jason isn't finished with you
yet let's go back into the cabin one
more time we are now on version 1.6 of
the cabin otherwise referred to as new
game + + I was completely stuck here so
I did a little bit of digging online and
discovered that we can use the Konami
code in Friday the 13th simply press up
up down down left right left right B a
which is circle X on a Playstation this
unlocks the debug mode you're going to
change a few options here first change
show collisions to on and then try
turning off the maps collisions
I admit that one scared the bejesus out
of me again if we get the unknown error
message this proves we are on track to
finish this one go back to the room with
the red dot and now look at it
it's a glitching mess walk straight
through it I don't know how to explain
this one we are stuck in a secret room
listen to the walkie-talkie
to get out of here simply walk into the
flying patches and we have now unlocked
patch 1.7 this world is very unstable
and the characters are glitching in and
out of position simply follow the
patches to keep this experience going oh
and look who makes a cameo the CEO of
ill phonic drops by what a nice guy
make your way to the basement of course
stopping to check out Jenny's but again
in the basement grab the final patches
from the Jason statues and enjoy another
brutalizing
here we have the final step follow all
the badges to the coming soon room which
will spawn you into something that looks
like a spaceship I'm sure you already
know what's coming here look around the
ship and when you're ready flip the
switch on the door and enjoy what all
your hard work has achieved
oh my god we are getting uber Jason
under Grendel map what an awesome
revealed honestly potentially the
greatest reveal I have ever seen one
last thing to enjoy before the calving
tour is over loading back into the
virtual cabin launch cheese patch 2.0 go
down to the basement and now all the
glass cabinets are back with the
addition of the cheeky little part one
Jason and of course Jason X how freaking
fantastic is that anyway we did it we
survived the virtual cabin 2.0
experience please throw us a like if you
think this video is worth it and think
about subscribing if this is your type
of thing I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade it's been an absolute pleasure
I'll see you next time I bet I sound
like a right perv mmm Jennie's but it's
a good but it is a good [ __ ] going in
the video it's a good butt
you